et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
françois rebsamen bonjour france amène
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous en
direct de dijon dont vous êtes le maire
socialiste
vous êtes également le président de la
fédération nationale des élus
socialistes on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par jefferson des
sports qu'on est ravi de revoir sur ce
plateau dont jean pierre salles dont
joue orione changer si s'ouvrait le
sommet mha sud ouest france à rennes on
commence bien sûr avec la crise
sanitaire et jean castex le premier
ministre qui était donc hier soir sur
france 2 pour faire de la pédagogie
expliquées voire justifiées
la stratégie du gouvernement sur cette
crise sanitaire est ce qu'il vous a
convaincu le premier ministre
personnellement j'ai trouvé que les
positions qui le développe est qu il
expliqué était juste nous sommes
confrontés à une crise sanitaire
il est de la responsabilité du
gouvernement de de prendre des décisions
est proposé des décisions aux élus
locaux mois à dijon je peux affirmer
aujourd'hui que je travaille en pleine
concertation avec le préfet et nous
durcirons si nécessaire les mesures que
qui ont déjà été prises donc c'est pas
facile pour le gouvernement faut le
reconnaître
les indicateurs varient souvent
souvent ils sont incomplets donc il faut
changer de ligne de crête
il faut maintenir la vie économique et
en même temps il faut prendre les
mesures pour éviter que ne soit amené à
reprofiler bien évidemment françois
rebsamen
renaud muselier déposent aujourd'hui un
référé contre la fermeture des bars et
des restaurants à métropole d'aix
marseille
est ce que vous auriez pris la même
décision j'aurais pas je n'aurais pas
forcément pris la même décision mais je
n'ai pas les éléments pour porter
jugement aujourd'hui ce que je vois
c'est que effectivement il ya une
profession que je connais à dijon nous
avons cinq cent cinquante restaurants
énorme pour l'activité économique
donc on voit bien que cette profession
est très très en danger
il faut absolument les aider les
accompagner mais
il s'y li a nécessité de prendre ces
décisions
moi je fais confiance en la matière au
premier ministre ça veut dire
concrètement françois rebsamen que si
demain dijon olivier verdi à dijon il
faut fermer les bars et les restaurants
vous ne vous ne vous y opposerait pas
moi je discuterai avec le préfet c'est
ce que je nous faisons nous avons déjà
diminuer les heures d'ouverture des bars
de nuit il ya eu ce bar de nuit tout ou
ferme à deux heures du matin et 6 soit
s'il faut fermer à 11 heures du soir
concernant ce genre de soir on suit ça
très précisément ce qui est inquiétant
mais ça c'est le seul point sur lequel
j'ai des divergences d'analysé que dans
l'eau dans nos capitales régionales
nous testons énormément parce que nous
avons des chu et donc viennent se faire
tester des habitants de tous les
départements alentour alors c'est
effectivement sur les métropoles que on
a le plus de test donc on a le plus de
deux taux d'incidence est donc c'est à
prendre en compte c'est pas forcément
qui les habitants la métropole mais
enfin il faut une très bonne décision et
s'il faut prendre des décisions plus
strictes on les prendra françois
rebsamen le gouvernement est toujours
entre deux urgences l'urgence sanitaire
l'urgence économique
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir un juste
milieu vous l'avez dit il faut discuter
oui c'est une ligne de crête n'est pas
facile j'étais très inquiet au début de
la rentrée scolaire parce que dans ma
ville par exemple sans prévenir personne
l'éducation nationale je veux pas dire
qui exactement mais l'éducation
nationale a pris la décision de fermer
des écoles là où il y avait un enfant de
5 ans qui était qui avait locaux vides
j'ai trouvé ça absolument stupide
résultat les gens des personnels
soignants pouvais plus aller soigner les
gens parce que vous êtes obligés de
garder leurs enfants alors qu'eux mêmes
qui avec un calme maintenant s'est
assouplie mais ça a été long et
difficile
ça manque de réactivité sur certains
sujets c'est vrai l'éducation nationale
c'est c'est quand même une grosse
machine et eux l'éducation nationale
elle ferait bien de travailler plus sans
concertation avec les maires c'est pas
toujours le cas justement sur ces
concertations venu dit que vous avez des
discussions avec le gouvernement olivier
ferrand qui a cité un dijon parmi les
métropoles qui pourrait passer un nid
rouge plus foncée où vous en êtes
aujourd'hui de ces discussions et quelle
est la situation sanitaire précisément à
dijon nous avons ce soir une réunion
comme toutes les semaines avec le préfet
et la rs pour étudier des derniers
résultats sur des semaines glissant
puisque c'est comme ça qu'on prend les
chiffres nous avons un taux d'incidence
qui est aux alentours de 100 et nous
avons un taux de positivité qui est
juste en dessous de ça donc il n'ya pas
encore nécessité de prendre des mesures
drastiques mais ils sont prendre un
certain nombre de monsieur françois
rebsamen vous parlez de concertation est
ce que les annonces faites par olivier
ferrand que les élus locaux ont
découvert lors de ces annonces justement
marque une rupture dans la méthode
castex au début quand il arrive à
matignon
il fait ce lien avec les yeux locaux il
dit qu'il faut discuter
or quand on voit l'attitude des élus
marseillais aujourd'hui il y aurait une
rupture c'est votre sentiment ou pas moi
je ne le constate pas des gens mais pour
autant il est possible qu'à marseille il
n'y a pas eu la possession nécessaire
elle est indispensable parce que sont
les communes les villes les métropoles
l'éventuelle non mais les villes qui
agissent concrètement sur le terrain
c'est cessé vers nous que se tourner nos
concitoyens c'est pas vers olivier
ferrand donc je je je lui demande de
continuer à pratiquer ce qu'avait
demandé le premier ministre à savoir moi
je le fais bien ici en bourgogne franche
comté avec le préfet mais c'est que ce
soit le cas partout est-ce que marseille
est une exception vous vous êtes
président de la fédération nationale des
élus socialistes vous êtes également
monde de france urbaine y avait eu une
réunion hier ce sont les élus des
grandes villes des métropoles
vous avez forcément parlé avec vos
collègues vous dites que c'est plutôt
marseille l'exception et que jean castex
consultons que c'est plutôt dijon
l'exception et qu'il ya un manque de
concertation
non les maires que j'ai rencontrés ne ne
se plaignent pas majoritairement sur l
exception nous ne citer les bouches du
rhône ne l'a peut-être d'autres ne se
plaignent pas de ne pas avoir de
concertation locale avec avec avec la
grèce alors à martial sûrement eu un
manque de concertation
ça c'est possible moi je suis j'ai pas
les éléments qui nous permettent de
porter jugement avec les préfets mais
avec le gouvernement avec olivier
ferrand
olivier ferrand faut pas qu'il oublie
qu'il a été
élu local et que on a vu que dans la
crise sanitaire ce qui marchait pas
c'étaient les décisions nationales qu'on
n'essaye aide à pulse et verticalement à
travers des décisions prises à paris
donc la méthode qui a proposé le premier
ministre négociations au niveau local
pour tenir compte réellement de la
situation c'est là c'est la bonne c'est
loeb c'est la bonne proposition c'est
comme ça que j'ai la tendance à oublier
qu'il a été élu local olivier ferrand
peut-être des fois oui peut-être des
fois c'est sa fonction ministérielle qui
aimait ça françois rebsamen est ce que
vous craignez une incompréhension dans
la population par rapport à ce
durcissement des mesures parce que pour
le coup les élus locaux vont être en
première mesure justement pour faire
cette pédagogie
oui c'est normal on a fait on a fait
cette pédagogie en le profil mans moi
j'ai fait le nombre de vidéos qui ont
été vue des dizaines de milliers de fois
par les habitants de ma ville pour leur
dire ce que nous faisions c'est notre
rôle de leur expliquer de faire cette
pédagogie
moi je trouve à dijon mais je ne peux
pas porter jugement ailleurs que
globalement à 90% à 95% les les gens
respectent les consignes que nous
prenons par exemple nous avons interdit
avec le préfet les journées
d'intégration dans les écoles
d'ingénieurs dans toutes ces grandes
écoles de l'enseignement supérieur alors
ce qui est vrai c'est que les jeunes qui
ont 20 ans et qui sont beaucoup moins
malades ils prennent moins de précaution
alors pour leur rappeler qu'ils doivent
protéger les personnes fragiles on va
passer un autre sujet puisque jean
castex n'a pas parlé que de crises
sanitaires hier il a aussi parlé de
sécurité vous êtes l'un des spécialistes
de la sécurité c'est un sujet vous
suivez beaucoup il a notamment fait des
annonces en matière de sécurité d'
amélioration de la réponse judiciaire il
a parlé de la création de juges pénaux
de proximité pour mettre fin à
l'impunité pour les petits délits est ce
que c'est une bonne chose
absolument c'est attendu j'avais
l'épreuve de sécurité ça peut être pas
été bien présenté hier par les par les
maires qui peut être un peu stressée de
s'exprimer comme ça dans une grande
émission face à face au premier ministre
mais dans le domaine de la sécurité tout
commence par la prévention
et je pense qu'il hier on n'a pas
beaucoup insisté sur ce sujet c'est la
prévention autant que possible et c'est
la sanction dès que nécessaire
donc la prévention d'abord ensuite qu'à
la dissuasion la dissuasion c'est la
présence des policiers sur le terrain et
là ce qui me fait quand même un peu
sourire c'est de voir tous ces élus qui
pendant six ans avec nicolas sarkozy ont
soutenu la politique de nicolas sarkozy
terre ont supprimé 13 mille postes de
policiers dire aujourd'hui c'est vrai
oui on manque de deux postes de
policiers alors emmanuel emmanuel macron
il a oui j'en passe quel souci bien sûr
je lui ai dit quand il est venu à dijon
emmanuel macron il a pris l'engagement
de recruter 2000 postes de policiers
chaque année supplémentaire c'est une
bonne mesure jeu mais il faut aller
encore plus loin
on a perdu cette habitude de voir des
policiers dans le quartier parce qu'ils
sont pas assez nombreux et donc il ya
beaucoup de mesures de réforme assez
enfin il ya la sanction je disputerai un
peu long mais c'est clair la sanction
elle doit être immédiate
les plaines la plus rapide possible
sinon elle n'a aucune valeur exemplaire
est donc là dessus s'il ya des juges de
proximité qui font que celui qui met
réveille toutes les nuits tout le monde
en faisant des rodéos en moto il sera
pas convoquée dans un an devant le
tribunal pour pour dire voilà
non il faut que immédiatement il ya une
sanction proportionnée
bien sûr à l'acte commis s'agit pas de
dire que les magistrats sont laxistes et
magistrats ils n'arrivent ils ne sont
pas assez nombreux pour répondre en
temps et donc ça c'est une bonne mesure
enfin tout le monde oublie de parler des
victimes
mais moi j'aimerais bien être par
exemple quand on arrête de ski ça arrive
assez souvent des voyous et dans les
quartiers ans préviennent les habitants
que ça a été fait mais ça c'est à
l'étude là elle s'est perdue aussi il ya
beaucoup de choses à revoir domaine de
la sécurité
alors justement la sécurité c'est aussi
la justice vous l'avez dit françois
rebsamen
il va y avoir une augmentation du budget
de la justice de 8% à la lueur de ce que
vous venez de dire on imagine que vous
êtes satisfait de cette annonce oui
c'est une bonne c'est une bonne décision
j'indique soussou françois hollande dans
prochaine dans le précédent quinquennat
les mois à dijon il ya l'école nationale
des greffes les greffiers ils sont
indispensables à la vie de la justice il
ya un plan de recrutement qui avait été
lancée le problème souvent des
gouvernements qui se succèdent ce qu'il
n'y a pas de gestion prévisionnelle des
effectifs dans la fonction publique
alors moi je suis très heureux d'une
augmentation de 10 % du budget de la
justice mais faut pas que ce soit juste
one one shot j'allais dire un ou une
fois il faut que ce soit en continuité
parce qu on a beaucoup de retard
beaucoup de retard dans le domaine de la
justice
est ce que vous craignez françois
rebsamen que ce débat sur la sécurité
viennent finalement un polluer un peu la
vie politique dans les prochains mois il
y beaucoup de faits divers
cet été est ce que vous craignez que ce
sujet redeviennent prégnant il est
prégnant cc c'est ma grande inquiétude
la drogue se répand dans toutes les
villes
il ya des points de vente un peu partout
qui a été favorisée encouragé par le
papa le confinement en période de
confinement et et on a l'impression par
moments dans nos villes d'être d'être
submergés par sept points de vente de
drogue
c'est donc il faudra peut-être un jour
avoir le courage d'avoir une réflexion
sur cette loi de 1970 qui nous régit
toujours qui est la loi la plus
répressive d'europe et pour autant ce
nous sommes le pays où il ya le plus de
consommation de drogue il ya quelque
chose qui ne va pas est-ce qu'on
pourrait un jour avoir une discussion
sereine entre élus et responsables du
gouvernement pour dire exactement
comment on peut avancer c'est ça pose la
question peut-être la dépénalisation du
cannabis
on a vu un ministre en tout cas de
l'intérieur très offensif sur ce sujet
là quelle est votre position françois
rebsamen
non je ne pense pas qu'ils aillent
dépénaliser comme ça le cannabis ce
serait une travers non jeu ce que je
pense ce qu'il faut d'abord mettre en
place des sanctions proportionnées
mais immédiate réel qui n'encombre pas
la police parce que la procédure est
aujourd'hui beaucoup trop longue nokia
la contravention nalisation qui a été
avancé je crois qu'elle est expérimenté
dans quelques endroits pense que c'est
une bonne mesure
je l'avais proposé à françois hollande
mais il n'avait pas eu le courage de
l'âme et rohner donc une bonne mesure il
dharmanand sur ce sujet sur la
contravention nalisation oui bien sûr il
faut que les il faut que les
les petits dealers on paye des amendes
et s icd mineur il faut que les parents
soient informés
parce que si l'on laisse les choses
comme ça on fait des procédures très
longues pour les policiers ils perdent
des millions d'heures de travail pour
concert des procédures qui n'aboutissent
à rien donc soit on a quand même
réfléchir sereinement ensemble autre
sujet franck la même semaine c'est ce
discours d' emmanuel macron sur le
séparatisme qui est attendue vendredi
prochain il devrait annoncer les grandes
lignes de la future loi de lutte contre
les séparatismes qu'est ce que vous
attendez de ce discours est à ce qu'il
faut vraiment une loi sur ce sujet selon
vous moi j'aime pas trop quand on aborde
ces sujets sous un angle très
idéologique
ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui vu l'état de
notre société sait rassembler les
français et donc le président de la
république de temps en temps il y la
tendance quand même à se laisser aller à
des petites réflexions il l'avait arrêté
qui peuvent donner l'impression qu'on
divise les français il faut absolument
que bien évidemment non d'entendre le
cadre de l'éthique républicaine qu'on
rassemble l'ensemble des français les
divergences politiques ce sont des
choses c'est la démocratie
mais sur les enjeux essentiels tu as
défense de la république sur la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité
il faut rien lâcher mais vous craignez
vous craignez que ce discours est le
fait de s'attaquer à ces sujets ça ça
clive ça divise la société française ça
dépend de quelle manière il abordera je
lui fais confiance je suis très modeste
je ne donne pas de bons conseils au
président la république
en tous les cas je dis une chose qu'il
faut rassembler allez on va parler du
parti socialiste maintenant et olivier
faure qui a donc annoncé un congrès mi
décembre il est candidat ou à son
renouvellement il traite à nouveau être
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
vous le soutenez c'était la question ne
se pose pas du soutien de l'église je
pense qu'il est d'ailleurs incertain le
seul candidat
vous voyez ça sera pas la vraie question
aujourd'hui c'est c'est parce que les
leviers forts et idy rassemblement
rassemblement rassemblement mais sur
quoi piquer le programme moi ce que je
veux savoir c'est quelle est le
programme aujourd'hui de la la sociale
démocratie écologique que je représente
avec beaucoup d'autres quelques et
qu'est ce qu'est ce qui les différencier
qu'est ce qui nous rassemble avec les
écologistes
je suis un homme qui croit en progrès au
progrès social au progrès
environnemental
progrès économique je crois à la science
je ne suis pas un écologiste radicale
mais je suis un écologiste maire
socialiste qui agit concrètement pour
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique par contre les histoires du
tour de france de sapins ça montre une
radicalité insupportable on en
arriverait à retourner à l'économie de
subsistance
donc ça ce n'est pas question sur ce
point là je pense que nous devons être
au clair on nous ne sommes pas plaire
est le parti socialiste n'a pas assez
travaillé depuis deux ans il n'y a pas
eu lieu une convention de réflexion bon
c'est le sait c'est vraiment en ses
fameux g plat pour les idées c'est pas
du tout un soutien à olivier faure pour
vous et il a mal dirigé ce parti depuis
deux ans il a dirigé la presqu'île
ouvert il a dirigé il a fait ce qu'il
pouvait simplement je constate
je constate qu'il n'y a pas eu de débat
d'idées que derrière les mots
rassemblement il ne se passe strictement
rien parce qu'on ne se met pas au clair
on devrait déjà avoir notre propre
réflexion et ensuite les changes et les
écologistes mois que je suis pour le
rassemblement avec des élus écologistes
mais sur quoi on se rassemble sur le
fait d'interdire les sapins dans les
centre-villes sur le fait de dire que le
tour de france ça pollue non mais c'est
quoi cette histoire
françois rebsamen qu'est ce que vous
pensez de l'initiative de laurent
joffrin qui veut justement faire vivre
cette social-démocratie dont vous parlez
moi je pense que toutes les personnes
qui aujourd'hui lancent des idées pour
du débat moi je souhaite qu'il y ait on
n'attend pas les programmes encodage
j'écoutais sénateurs qui était avec vous
précédemment un programme en commun ça
ne peut se faire que quand il y à des
débats et des échanges et les échanges
c'est vers quoi on avance ensemble et
pas on est ensemble on est ensemble on
pourrait dire et on peut crier sur son
petit siège unité unité unité 6 il n'y a
pas d'idée derrière ça ne sert à rien
donc oui il ya un programme en commun à
condition qu'ils soient débattues
partout en france et que nous ne soyons
clairs sur nos propres idées sur ce
qu'on est prêt à accepter ou françois
observé ce cas si vous le permettez à
mot ce qui est en train de se passer
dans les villes c'est que j'ai entendu
il ya eu des rassemblements avec les
écologistes
bien sûr qu'il ya une meilleure des
primaires partout au premier tour
partout partout partout
quand il y avait un candidat socialiste
et un candidat écologiste est toujours
sauf à poitiers c'est toujours le code
la socialiste qui arrivait en tête
alors après qu'il y ait une fusion au
deuxième tour quand les écologistes ne
veulent c'est normal mais vous savez où
vous allez vous retrouver avec une
majorité où il ya des radicaux
écologistes ça va pas être ça ça va pas
être simple dans certaines villes de
l'ouest de la france
qu'est ce que vous pensez françois
rebsamen est ce qu'il faut un candidat
socialiste en 2022 à la présidentielle
est ce que vous craignez un effacement
du parti socialiste parce que olivier
faure est prêt à se ranger derrière un
candidat écologiste pour 2022
c'est à dire que je n'ai pas de position
personnelle la bolivie et fort je parle
aussi d je n'imagine pas qu'un cas parti
comme le parti socialiste n'est pas de
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
donc florida estampillés parti
socialiste très clair oui mais il peut
très bien être le candidat du
rassemblement à l'audition qu'ils aient
socialistes la position qu'ils aient eu
une discussion je pense que j'ai dis
parce que tout commence par là qui est
une sorte d'états généraux de la gauche
où on puisse se rassembler ensemble
avancer ensemble et ensuite désigné
notre candidat mais évidemment qu'il
faut que la social-démocratie écologiste
et sociale écologie elle doit être
présentée de l'élection présidentielle
justement françois rebsamen qui pour
incarner cette social-démocratie est ce
que ce serait anne hidalgo par exemple
est ce que ce serait françois hollande
non françois hollande je suis beaucoup
d'estimé pour françois long mais c'est à
mon avis et c'est plus d'actualité annie
la luz une bonne candidate stéphane le
foll on arnaque les candidats se
séparent le c'est pas le sujet
aujourd'hui c'est comment qu'est ce qui
représente qu est-ce qui porte est-ce
qu'on se rassembler avec lui ce
rassemblement
quel calendrier pour le faire ce que le
temps tourne déjà pour le parti
socialiste françois rebsamen le temps
tour mais il ya des élections avant et
ces élections elles sont importantes
il ya les élections sénatoriales
dimanche elles vont pas changer grand
chose mais on va constater le recul de
en marche évidemment et puis il ya des
élections régionales et départementales
elles sont elles sont très importantes à
ces élections là on constatera que le le
parti du président de la république a
quasiment disparu
donc il y aura à en tirer les leçons et
surtout à passer à l'élection majeure
après ces élections régionales deux
questions rapidement pour finir françois
rebsamen sur france urbaine un congrès
avait lieu hier c'est johanna rolland
qui est la nouvelle présidente la maire
socialiste de nantes et c'est donc à
jean luc moudenc était de droite ne le
maire de toulouse l'association même si
on sait qu'elle est pluraliste
elle bascule à gauche en tout cas sa
présidence vous vous en féliciter oui
oui je l'avais indiqué des lendemains de
l'élection municipale à jean luc moudenc
avec lequel nous entretenons des
relations amicales c'est normal dans une
association pluraliste et donc j'avais
revendiquer pour moi cette présidence au
nom au nom de la gauche
mais les élus écologistes radicaux ont
emporté avec eux j'ai eu alain rolland
et donc c'est elle qui a été désignée
j'ai été j'ai été battu à la primaire je
voulais paquet division des socialistes
je m'en étais entretenu avec martine
aubry
et donc il était important que jaka seul
candidat donc j'ai voté pour johanna
rolland y ait de la fin du parti
socialiste à l'ancienne je dirais du
fait des écologistes mais bien sûr qu'il
doit s'allier avec les écoles
il a commencé à s'allier avec lionel
jospin en 1997 et j'ai pris ma part
j'avais par exemple été soutenir la
candidature de dominique voynet voyez à
tavaux à dole tavaux
donc c'est pas d'aujourd'hui qui a eu
des rassemblements mais à l'époque ça se
faisait sur un programme
ça ne tiendra que si ça se fait sur un
programme sinon vous allez avoir en
permanence et nous aller le voir et
c'est pas fini des couacs au sein des
majorités municipales parce que les
écologistes demanderont des choses et
les socialistes qui n'auront pas
débattue avant sur le fond l adhérent
autre chose et donc
et quand il y a quand il ya pas de la
clarté la seule la clarté finalement
c'était jean jaurès et révolutionnaire
dernier mot rapidement puisqu'on parle
d'écologie sur dijon qui est finaliste
pour être capitale verte
1022 qu'est ce que cela signifierait
pour dijon ça ça serait le couronnement
de 20 ans d'efforts c'est avec les élus
écologistes d'ailleurs pour porter cette
cette ville à devenir une sorte
d'exemple de l'écologie urbaine alors
l'écologie urbaine nous c'est respect
bien sûr de l'environnement mais c'est
surtout de lutter côté les gaz à effet
de serre de produire de l'énergie
renouvelable d'associer là population à
cela dijon a la chance d'être une une
ville verte c'est déjà ça ne doit pas
qu'à moi monsieur
mais par contre tout ce que nous faisons
pour lutter contre les gaz à effet de
serre et limiter les débats soir
thermique avoir de la production verte
hydrogène photovoltaïques tout ça c'est
nous qui le faisons
merci beaucoup françois rebsamen et
patience à dijon merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct depuis votre ville de
dijon merci jefferson vous regarde la
une de sud ouest ce matin qu vide ce qui
nous attend en gironde
et puis on regarde votre livre jefferson
consacré à alain juppé bordeaux la chute
de la maison juppé j'espère qu'on aura
l'occasion d'en parler dans ce club des
territoires merci d'être venu bien sûr
rien n'est jefferson et on parce que
justement club détériore la mutuelle
nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux
vous présente le club des territoires
angie acteurs engagés dans la transition
zéro carbone des régions vous présente
le club des territoires
m